so with no further ado i will uh
introduce you to
rajiv hassan
thank you
and good morning welcome to this talk uh
my name is ragi bhasan i am the founder
of shikhar.com which is
a bengali language mooc designed for
students in south asia
and in my spare time i'm also an
assistant professor of computer science
at the university of alabama at
birmingham
so in this talk i'm going to discuss my
experiences in building
chicago bengali language mooc designed
with a specific target audience in mind
the students in
south asia in particular bangladesh and
india
but before i begin anything let's just
tell you the meaning of the word shikha
the word chicago means teacher
in bengali it's a bengali word i guess
it also means the same in hindi and a
bunch of other south asian languages
the
chicago project was founded in
exactly two years ago
august 1st 2012
and i established it as a
platform where
interested teachers with different
backgrounds different expertise can come
together
and teach or share their
knowledge in bengali language with
students in bangladesh and india
so we have a bunch of different
people here we have
i think right now we have 40 teachers
which were teaching in that platform
they're all volunteer teachers some are
professors some are scientists
researchers and if you look at the
pictures we also see one guy wearing a
chef's hat
is there anyone here from virginia tech
if there were someone from virgin tech
they will probably recognize this person
because he used to be the
chief executive chef of virginia tech
so
what are we doing here
we're trying to answer this question
how to
change the world by
bringing education to the masses with
very little inves little investment
little money
we can do that by using the power of
social media
the internet and the crowds
so this is a
a typical classroom in bangladesh
because i said typical because it's too
small usually the classes are much
bigger i remember when i was growing up
in bangladesh back in the 1980s i was
once in a classroom which had 100
students
in a much smaller room i guess
but
these are
the problems in rural bangladesh
in particular
the students
in low income from the low income
segment in the society who are in rural
areas they don't have access to quality
education sometimes they don't have even
access to any teachers who can teach
science and technology and math
so um
we have this huge problem that we're
going to provide top quality education
to all these students
but bangladesh as you know is not a rich
country so the government cannot provide
all the infrastructure for providing
this education to these disadvantaged
students
so how can we
solve this problem
to give you some more context about the
scale of the problem
uh it might be surprising to some of you
that bengali is actually the fourth
largest uh language in the world in
terms of native speakers there are about
30 300 million uh people in the in
bangladesh and the united states of west
bengal who speak bengali as their native
language
and in many cases
a large portion of these 300 million
people live in rural areas they maybe
have schools one school every few
villages
but the schools often lack teachers
because the government obviously cannot
afford to
put a lot of money and resources for
these purposes
and the problem is more acute in higher
education because there are so many
students every year who want to
who graduate from school and want to
enter universities but there are only
few positions
right now there are hardly 50 000
positions in bangladeshi
universities for incoming freshmen
but there are more than 300 000 to 400
000 students who want to enter these
positions
so a lot of the students
have no choice other than to dropping
out of college or dropping out right
after the high school level or even
after the primary school level
how can we solve this
our solution
is
to create a highly localized context
sensitive or culturally sensitive mooc
in bengali language which gives us a
hybrid internet and non-internet based
delivery mechanism to deliver our
content to the students
and to do that we use the power of
crowdsourcing
both for content generation and also for
deployment and marketing and getting our
content to the students
if we wanted to start this project 10
years ago that would probably not be
possible
because
in bangladesh
even today not a lot of people have
access to computers
but
today
a lot of them have access to mobile
phones
the mobile phone penetration rate in
bangladesh this year is about 70 or
close more than 70 percent
which means a lot of these people
i have data from last year which shows
that 100 million people in bangladesh
have mobile phones these mobile phones
are not smartphones but they have do
have the capability of displaying small
videos playing audio and so on
so we're going to leverage this uh the
availability of mobile phones in even in
rural areas to create a bengal language
mooc which is highly optimized for
mobile devices
to in order to reach this rural student
and non-traditional students
at the same time we don't want to just
depend on the internet
so we want to create a mechanism a
supply chain for providing taking all
this content to all these students who
may not have access to the internet or
not even mobile phones
now the question is why are we trying to
reinvent the wheel because there are so
many nice smokes out there that have
been
um that were being developed in the last
five years what are we doing that's
different
well if you look at the moocs the mooc
development the major moocs that are
developed in the last few years you'll
see that most of them
were developed for english speakers
for students who understand english
for example right now coursera has 709
courses as of today and 86 percent of
them
that is 609 courses are designed or
delivered in english language
the khan academy which is very famous
for creating this web-based video
tutorials that are their videos are also
originally created in english
now the problem is uh
only a few people a few of the students
maybe five percent of six percent of the
students in bangladesh have the
necessary or required knowledge of
english that they would require to
understand these lectures that are given
in english
even people who
can understand english they actually
prefer uh tutorials that are in bengali
language their mother native language
and i've talked to students in
bangladesh at different levels and the
general idea i get from them is that
first of all they prefer lectures and
lessons to be in bengali language and
also
a lot of the
material being taught in these moocs
does not make any sense in their local
culture that is they
they would prefer
content that have been developed with
the local cultural cues and teaching
techniques in mind and also uh
most of the students in schools in
particular
they will they definitely want to learn
but they also want to
pass the
tests
so they would like to have material that
are that is designed with the
bangladeshi uh education system in mind
the syllabuses that is specific to the
bangladeshi system
so with this in mind uh
we developed shaka but let's let me also
give you some numbers or some studies we
did recently
i
asked students um
what if you are given the choice of
learning through a bengal language book
versus an english language book which
one would you prefer
overall we can see that 59 percent of
the students prefer a bengal language
mooc versus only 17 percent who
are fine with an english language move
i break i broke it down according to the
educational level of the respondents and
we found that
at the high school level
or school level
an overwhelmingly uh large number of
students 71 percent prefer bengali
over just uh 15 of those who would like
to
who are fine with an english language
book
as people get more get more education
say undergraduate degrees or graduate
degrees masters or phds
their
preference for bengali falls slightly
but still it's above 50 percent even for
people who are know english who have
graduate degrees
and we also we also looked at um the
educational the age breakdown you can
see that younger people
who uh have not mustered english yet
they are more interested in bengali
language moocs being a language content
whereas as people grow older it kind of
levels off at 50 percent
in terms of preference for bringing
language moocs
and then the other question i asked um
people or
was that
if you are given the choice of two moves
one is an english language mooc which
has been dubbed into bengali
versus another which
a native
bengali speaker has developed
with the knowledge of the local culture
local jokes and everything which one
would you prefer as you can see from
here
more than 62 percent of people
are interested in locally developed
content over just 30 percent of uh over
just eight percent of people who prefer
adopt one
so what does it tell us this tells us
that people would like to have content
that have been developed locally versus
content that have been developed for the
whole world and just translated into
each language individually
so we started chicago.com we had these
requirements in mind and we decided that
the irrigation medium must be totally in
bengali it should be also be highly
optimized for mobile phones because
that's where what device most of the
students would like to have and then
the whole
process should also take very little
cost because there's obviously not a lot
of investment in education sector in
bangladesh and it also must not depend
on depends solely on the internet to
deliver the content
so there are many challenges in this
project for example how do we find the
best tools and design principles what
kind of videos should work best in this
situation
how do you find the teachers
since we are a virtual organization we
don't have a physical presence so all
the teachers are spread all around the
world how do we find and coordinate them
and then how do we get to the students
that we're targeting
the first challenge is definitely cost
uh as a professor i don't have millions
of dollars
every year so
um how do you find this thing most of
the popular moocs have millions of
dollars of venture capitalist funding uh
22 million dollars for coursera i think
a few years from a few years ago but
probably it's more than that now
and in bangladesh there's obviously no
such funding how do you find this thing
and then the language barrier is
important because
most of the target audience does not
they don't speak english
even they speak english they would
prefer bangla
and then
how do you find the teachers how do you
reach the
stakeholders all these are technical
challenges
our solution to this problem is to
explore different hci methods and
iterative design and rapid prototyping
to figure out what's the best way of
teaching
in such a
situation
and then we also
look for extreme pain pinching methods
to find out how can we design the whole
platform at a very low cost
we also use
make extensive use of social media
for everything for finding teachers
finding students
announcing our and getting our content
all everything to the students and
finally our last solution is to use
non-internet-based supply chains to
deliver the content to the rural
students
i'll skip the part about the design
strategies but basically we try out
different prototypes of lectures for
example longer lectures versus shorter
lectures lectures with interactive quiz
lectures without that and so on where
and through this rapid prototyping and
measuring the student response
we tried to figure out the best way of
reaching the students
and
then about the cost
the whole cost of the platform over the
last two years has been
15
the price of three big macs
why is it so little because
we don't have a fancy website it's just
a wordpress based uh website and i try
to find the cheapest host out there
which is five dollars or maybe ten
dollars per year which gives you just
100 megabytes of space
but
we also found a lot of free web
resources such as youtube vimeo and many
many other generous companies who hosted
our content for free
so with this small investment we're able
to reach
20 000 students in the first six months
right now the number is at least four
times or five times that
and over the last two years we have
developed and delivered 55
courses every day we have
about 4 500 to maybe 6 000 lecture views
from 3 000 at least 3 000 unique
visitors
and that's just the website uh i'm
talking about the internet based
channel i'm talking about
so um we also use whatever free
technology that's out there for example
we use google forms and google scripts
to design a quiz system
that automatically email the results
back to the students
so all the free technology out there is
really useful if you are trying to
design a mooc for 15
and everything was crowdsourced from all
the way from the site design to the
courses
to get those teachers i announced on
facebook and other social media
and on the first day i had 10 volunteers
who signed up to teach courses and then
by day two we had two courses running
by the week 8 15 courses
right now after 24 months we have 55
courses in our website
now a major challenge is okay we have
all this content but how do we deliver
this to the students how do we get the
content to the students so how internal
obviously
a lot of the students in rural areas
will not have access to the internet so
how can we deliver that
we have three approaches for doing that
the first approach is if students don't
have internet maybe they have mobile
phones
so we took our videos uh made them into
3gp format or mobile friendly formats
and
given gave those videos to mobile phone
vendors in rural rural shops and rural
bazaars
so people go to bazaars and usually a
lot of people go to buzzers and these
mobile phone shops to load
music videos on their phones
we said hey we have this free
lectures and if you're a student you're
interested you can get these lectures
from the small phone shops maybe the
mobile phone shop will charge maybe five
cents per video or less than that
and that
an interest in student even in rural
areas can afford that much money and
load that video in their mobile phones
the next one was partnership with cable
tv operators and that was interesting
because
we're not talking about cable tv
networks because that would be a huge
thing but we're talking about this rural
or
small city cable tv operators who
distribute the content we went to them
and gave them our content for free they
were really happy because they are
getting the content for free and they
could start a channel just for shika and
then they could show maybe ads on the
channel or anything they could do
whatever with that but as long as they
were showing our videos they served our
students as well as us
and the third solution is for places
where maybe the students don't even have
any mobile phones or anything else to
play their videos in that case we
provided the videos to schools and we
are not assuming that the schools will
have multimedia projectors or anything
so we put we
stuffed all our a lot of our videos in
this mobile uh
or sim cards or actual memory cards
and put them on raspberry pi devices so
we gave that these raspberry pies to
schools all they have to do is to find
them maybe an old unused tv
and they can connect this to the tv and
they can have these video lectures
so um we also figure out different users
engagement studies that if you have a
commenting system based on social media
that really gets people interested and
leads them to discuss more
we also figured out social media
marketing strategies um they found that
there's an actual optimal time for
posting announcements about our courses
which is 10 10 30 p.m at night during
weekdays any other time people will not
notice any content
so what we have achieved
in this project we have
demonstrated that
it's possible to
have more impact if you have localized
strategies based on local cultural
context and local languages than a
one-size-fits-all solution for the whole
world
and we also created a design set of
design principles for
creating this kind of um mobile based
content delivery systems um
uh we found which
kind of video lectures work and which do
not
and then um
we the biggest thing we have achieved
here in this project is to create
a micro lesson model which can be
replicated in many other developing
countries which have limited resources
as bangladesh
so uh time for some results some numbers
over to our impact
we started in august 1 2012 which is
exactly two years ago right now we have
55 courses and all these courses are
on a lot of different topics we have
school silver curriculum courses such as
math science and so on
we also have advanced courses such as
cancer nanotechnology which is taught by
an expert in that area
and then we also have
a course on learning chess a course on
learning the korean language and finally
a course on french culinary arts which
is stored by the virginia tech chef
so
we don't require our students to
register so the anyone can just go into
the website to look at things look at
our lectures but we do request them to
maybe it's a good thing to figure
register so we
request
uh that if they could register that's
good but they don't have to
so
so far we have 80 000 registered
students
and the actual number of students is
much bigger we have uh close to 500 000
uh returning visitors who come to our
sites from time to time and now in each
of our courses we have
four thousand or five thousand um people
each each of the popular courses we have
up to five thousand people who have
actually signed up
and then the total number of unique
visitors
uh in the first two years is 1.2 million
and we just delivered our 3.8 millionth
lecture
last week
and then
uh we're getting about 5000 to 6000
lecture views per day
and
but the most important thing that really
matters is that we are able to serve a
community which are which was outside
the education system for example i get
emails like this from students in
bangladesh who said that they wanted to
study a lot of different things but they
were not able to study that because of
poverty or other causes
and in the last year we got a few hours
from google or and the internet society
and so on
right now we have our
set of future goals for this year to
create
math and science courses science courses
for the school system in bangladesh
and to reach at least 200 000 students
in 100 schools through our offline
distribution mechanism
so summary of lessons we learned from
this project four lessons the first one
is it's possible to design successful
moocs at a very low cost if you use the
cloud source model of creating moocs
rather than the
centralized model other moocs have taken
and then iso-centric designs work well
and
if you want to you reach the
rural students
non-internet based delivery methods
really work and finally but most
importantly localized native language
education is perhaps much better than
a globalized english language
teaching method that most other moves
have taken my ending thought is
educating millions at a very low cost is
possible if we take a localized approach
and if you're interested to see uh
chicago.com in action you can visit that
it's in bengal language so maybe you'll
need a translator
and
i'll um just give you a
quick demo of the courses we have
this is a course form
maybe in response to a question we can
do that because we're past the
show the presentation time sure so but
we can look at some of the um examples
sure sure
now thanks for listening to the talk and
feel free to start the discussion
um so the next part of the discussion
first off are there any uh questions for
raghi but if you want to see the demo we
can do that next too i just wanted to
honor the time sets that we had set
oh yeah oh yeah curious
how the instructors collaborate how you
bring them into the system can you talk
a little bit more about the
crowdsourcing community model well um i
have to thank facebook and other social
media for that because um i find
teachers
through the social media
we have a page for this project which
has i think 30 000 or more people who
like that page through that and through
my followers in facebook i can reach a
large number of
people who are interested in
educating in being a language
and also sometimes i would also reach
out to experts in some particular domain
for example
the chef from virginia tech or someone
who
knows
neuroscience or cancer nanotechnology
i'd reach out to them and i'd request
them to create a course
and our courses are highly decentralized
because all the
content created the teachers are spread
all around the world
so they create their own videos in their
own time we do have a
kind of a like a technical advisory
group that helps in creating or in
educating these teachers about the
technical stuff for creating the videos
but other than that um
most of the collaboration among the
teachers would take place in social
media
okay
are there typically sort of the case you
mentioned there was one star created by
course is that ever the case that a
large school of teachers collaborates
throughout the course a single course
if so how do they
you know review each other's workers or
violent things like that how do the
dynamics work there uh i actually prefer
uh that a course
should be taught by one teacher because
otherwise students get kind of confused
if they have too many people teaching
different stuff
so um
we did have
maybe
a couple of courses that were team
taught
but still that were those were small
teams like for example two or three
people
and um their
the collaborator through maybe skype or
other digital media to help each other
in creating those contents
so i actually think that raises a really
interesting question around you bring up
crowdsourcing to create the content and
piotr you're bringing up another idea
which is using a different kind of crowd
sourcing not just the wiki model yeah so
i'm curious of other people um i don't
know i i can't recognize all your papers
by your faces so i'm curious if there
are other people in the room that have
tried alternative methods for sort of
crowdsourcing or collaborating around
content creation that you'd like to sort
of share with the group
okay so
does anyone have a
i don't know where your expertise in the
room is yeah
just comment um i don't think it's safe
for y'all is here um so safrion uh runs
801 and 2x at mit these are introductory
physics courses and he's sort of had a
long-standing relationship with teachers
who enroll in the courses uh that
actually offer up their services in
terms of creating content
reviewing material all kinds of things
that really
are happening quite naturally but
completely unexpected
and part of the plug that i'll do for my
box later is that that kind of work and
having seen safeguards interactions uh
had us release surveys asking me how
many people are teachers and actually
one in four identify as a teacher
right and it goes down i think to people
that are current teachers one and twenty
these are sort of shocking numbers
in terms of when you think of thousands
of participants i think it really
reframes
how we how we look at content course
creation and all these things
we should be harnessing
the collective potential of this group
yeah which is part of what your project
was doing was harnessing the collective
potential that's another one thing we
were also doing was to encourage people
to be teachers because in many cases
someone is an expert on a particular
topic but they don't have any previous
experience of teaching a course so what
we do is to
give them guidelines on how to create
lectures
some people are very shy and they want
they don't want to appear in front of a
camera so we teach them how to create
screencasting and record lectures in
that way so we basically guide people
who are maybe initially reluctant to
teach courses we kind of guide them
about teaching
styles teaching techniques and creating
these horses
so
yeah
so we had a project i'm ed cutron at
microsoft research in bangalore
and we have a project that's actually
slightly different i mean we're looking
at technical education looking at third
tier
colleges technical colleges things like
that and so
the thing that's interesting that i
think is relevant for this
might be interesting to talk about
is
the way people talk about what they want
to see
from the source of the information
and in fact what they
actually watch and enjoy watching and so
there's this idea of source effects
about you know who is teaching and
what's there for instance one of the
things that we were interested in was
you know when we first designed our
system it was to create
stuff that was taught by local teachers
um and our thing is all sort of like
it's meant to be for actual undergrads
so they're in the course and they're
taking it and one of the things we found
was that
there's something very aspirational
about say the stanford professor or
something like that and so they'll say
you know what i want is the stanford
professor
and yet
when we sort of watch how their behavior
is they can't understand him very well
and they have to like repeat it over and
over all this kind of stuff and so
there's this mix of this aspirational
thing versus in fact what
is probably the most useful and then we
we extended that further to say well
what about students in sort of purely
what if you get a student to teach a
given concept on the platform and use
that and what we found there was that
they really like the students
when it's a particular problem type
because the students can get right to
the nub but when you do this problem
this is what you got to know to do this
thing and the teachers tend to digress
about you know all the tedious actual
foundational reasons why you should know
this and stuff like that
um and so it was i mean i just i want to
bring that up because i think it's an
interesting distinction when you ask
people
they say one thing and then when they
are sort of performing it's something a
little different
you know what's interesting ed is
because ragibi did ask people and you
and they still told him they would
prefer a locally developed and what
you're saying is those numbers might not
even accurately represent as much that
preferences
no no no i'm saying that what what ed is
saying
actually uh not only confirms what
ruggee was saying but makes it even more
extreme because if you ask someone and
they're more likely to say i want this
but then what they really use is
something that's locally produced and so
that
we might say that your numbers aren't
even as don't demonstrate the effect as
much as as uh it actually exists that
your percentages there might be a higher
percentage of people that actually would
benefit more from the locally produced
language
language
advocate and i can say that
i mean they might appreciate because
more but in the long run they need to
learn english
if they're going to participate in their
own but most of them will never use in
english in any context
student in rural areas they just want to
learn the topic and maybe make a living
they are not going to pursue in internet
discussions they are not going to be in
the workforce right so i'm in the state
of bengal and india business experiment
primary education was
made compulsory in bengali an entire
generation
was left out of the workforce three
decades after that they still haven't
gone i i i i i
um definitely these students are
learning english but they are not
learning english to be fluent speakers
in english just participate in the
workforce
and i'm not saying because this reminds
me of there's a lot of work that
happened on same text subtitling
which you can do and they can pick up
english as they are watching the
lectures for instance that might be
something that can be incorporated here
so i think i mean this is great what are
you doing i mean it's brilliant i'm not
saying it's just that what about also
putting some way off you know the
workforce participation aspect so i
think that it depends on what the
learning goals are like is the learning
goal and what the learning goals are
would determine whether you uh focused
on that so i think there's some other
ideas coming back there yeah i actually
have questions for the group for
everybody but um the emphasis on teacher
training in some ways different from
what you're describing which is actually
sort of an emphasis on teaching students
to train
and isn't necessarily what your project
is all about it's much more sort of
direct
to consumer to student education
and i wonder whether people think there
should be more emphasis on teacher
creating these environments or
because there's a trade-off
and i also wonder whether
the actual tools used can be directed
more towards having students engage in a
way that allows them to continue this
beneficial cycle um
or not whether that was
intended but that will be invented
because i think that that kind of
globalization but actually for instance
translates
is key
so you're suggesting using these same
tools to put them in the hands not just
to crowdsourcing the teachers but
crowdsourcing students to also become
teachers and i think you were you were
doing something yes so for example um
i have reached out to students who are
good at programming and i ask them hey
why don't you teach a maybe a course in
ruby or python which you know really
well because you just took a course and
you
are maybe working in software company
part time why did you teach a course and
often they would say that they have
never taught such a course they don't
know how to teach a course so the next
thing we do is to get them in touch with
someone who is experienced in teaching
such courses and
through this kind of
peer
teaching uh
the students uh get to learn how to
develop these lectures
and another point i have not mentioned
is to how do how to create the lecture
videos many people think that they'll
need a studio setup or anything like
that for lecture videos but in fact is
we found that even a screencasting or
even a webcam is good enough for
creating effective videos as long as the
content is good and the
teaching is locally
contextualized
that you could be further achieving your
goals by
providing teacher training programs to
to that local population so that that
person used that you mentioned the
teacher shortage is a big which is one
of the biggest things and so then so
then that person could go on and reach
more people face it face to face
actually the government of bangladesh
has created a portal for teachers where
which at first sight looks like
something like this but it isn't because
there
teachers post their lectures but these
are not for students to see these are
for their peer teachers to see and
criticize critique and then uh they'll
the teachers are supposed to learn from
each other this is a undp funded project
and i think that's also something we
might consider in future
oh somebody sorry go ahead
you mentioned this delivery mechanism of
offline videos using mobile phones and
video mobile shops
so is there also some work being done
to integrate feedback mechanisms to do
quizzes or things like that they want to
ask a question
uh in this offline mechanism
yeah i would repeat the question because
they can't hear it so so the question is
i think i told me if i get your question
wrong so you're using these um
technologies to be able to disseminate
information but how do students give
feedback or how do they get questions
answered or how do they i would even
extend how do they demonstrate that
they're getting what it is that you're
hoping they're going to get so
we are trying to design systems of
getting correcting this feedback through
text messages so maybe a student watches
a video on their phones and then they
can text a particular number with some
answers or quizzes or maybe it's their
own questions
but still
this is so new that we're trying out
different techniques and another thing
we're going to test out in the next year
or so is to actually engage the local
schools
give them our content then collect data
about student tests course before and
after they have
used our content and maybe after a year
we can figure out how much impact this
content has yeah i'm curious has anyone
else used um like in low bandwidth
situations or mobile devices feedback
mechanisms like you're describing has
anyone else been doing that we have this
exact issue and one of the things i
would say is that in our context
we think of it more as a continuum of
access because i mean almost everybody
who has a mobile plan it's all prepaid
so so all of your data is pre-paid so
you have to think about that it's
differently from the north american
context
where you sort of have an
all-you-can-eat kind of situation there
you're thinking about every bite that
costs you some money
and as a result at least for our
students one of the things that they're
very interested in they're willing to
spend a little bit of money but not the
amount of money it's going to cost to
stream
and so what they'll do is that they'll
go and say go to the we have a system
set up so you can cash the stuff
on campus
they'll catch a bunch of the movies and
stuff but then they don't mind spending
a little bit of money to get online for
doing text kind of interactions and
things like that and so you can start
blending these things a little bit where
you're not costing them a huge amount of
money
for the video content
but it costs a little bit to engage in
say a low bandwidth website that you can
do things like quizzes where you can
actually make sure that the person is
who they say they are and that kind of
thing
yeah i mean so this is not the same
accommodation so we are doing something
similar with a telecom provider in
jordan for a pilot and what we're doing
is if you have a data subscription with
that provider accessing our site and
downloading streaming content doesn't
cost you anything exactly wikipedia zero
or other wikipedia exactly that's
actually what inspired
and i mean we're still piloting it it's
not perfect just because when we're
using open edx everything is hosted on
youtube and trying to sort of white
label youtube videos is an issue so
we're trying to see you know do we host
them on amazon servers and have people
download them for free but that's
something we're trying and people are
very receptive
so that's a great solution for the
streaming content have you do you have a
solution you're using for doing the
interaction so for us
so actually the driving is very easy to
access for free because it's actually on
the site so any anybody that has a sort
of a data package with that specific
telecom provider can access our site
already for free anything whether it's
sort of the feedback the discussion
forums doing the tests everything is
completely for free with caveat assuming
you have a data subscription with that
telecom provider it could be as low as
sort of two or three dollars but for
some people it's still a barrier
uh the issue becomes with the video
because they're streaming them on
so
youtube
did similar surveys in senegal using
medic mobile which is actually a health
care software not educational data
whatsoever but they were all by sms and
it's the best forms can you speak up
sure you had a data plan that was by a
data connection you've had forms using
ob or other data lists but when it was
just by sms you could actually have the
exact same content at least as part of
the quiz or questionnaire was concerned
delivered by sms
and the providers i'm sure that all the
sms is coming from again the source and
we're provided with recharge and
responses are also pretty charged so you
have total virus
i think you had another contribution so
i have a question not related to this
current discussion but it's not like um
so in terms of popularity one are more
popular like english language courses or
like technical courses
that's question number one number two is
like uh in terms of long-term mission do
you plan to introduce like english
language courses at the secondary school
level and the university level so that
as generations go through it will become
more fluent in english
so
such a long time too that's question
number two number one is that in terms
of right now plus more popular english
language courses or technical
well people are more interested in
technical courses in particular
i found that people right now are very
interested in mobile application
development we have five courses on that
ranging from people who don't even know
programming how can they use app
inventor to create mobile apps
to all the way to java and
see
c plus plus and other languages to
create
mobile apps so these five courses are
very popular we have at least four
thousand to five thousand students
registered in this courses and many more
to look at the content
and um
topics such as
maybe english language we have to have a
course for in teaching english which is
definitely taught in english so that is
targeted for
high school students of a particular
client
class
and that
they do have students but
that's not as popular as having 5000
students sign up for the course
and to answer second question definitely
that's something we might consider in
future right now our goal is to
make sure the students can understand
the topic in the best way possible maybe
in future when we we can experiment with
a few english language courses to see
how much responses we get from the
students
obviously we're dealing with a very
different population but very similar
issues the reason we launched iraq is 80
of the arab world doesn't speak english
so anything in terms of edx coursera is
completely not available to them but
when we called people and this is not a
very good example so only 2 000 people
uh 47
said you know we want your next course
to be on teaching us english
so i wanted to know if have you actually
sort of asked people if they want to
learn english because unfortunately
we're working on creating on all these
arabic courses because yes in the short
term they're not going to be able to
access anything if they don't learn if
we don't provide the content in arabic
but for them whether it's sort of career
aspirations and we haven't dug deeper we
just asked you know what is the number
one of course you want why and everybody
say you know you won't learn english
well we didn't specifically ask them if
they want to learn english but we do
have a course on learning english
vocabulary specifically for taking
toefl or ilts and that course is very
very popular we have i think six
thousand people sign up for that course
so i guess that answers part of your
question and the other thing i want to
point out that uh
a lot of these surveys have some caviars
because uh you are
pulling a target and a population who
definitely has access to the internet
maybe they already know english so your
servers might be skilled it will be
really good to do an offline survey
involving the actual students
who might not speak english
approach also is a database
which is to see which either works
better either experimentally or just
correlationally one thing that i've been
doing a little bit is
looking at difference in performance on
problems being between students in the
developing world and sort of to the us
so that correlates with issues
cultural issues
uh which per capita obviously is
different
and as i look at this we're about 500
problems with the medics where sodas in
the u.s robert susan i'll be brought by
about 30 percent that's majority of them
performance was very similar but there
was a small set and now kind of diving
into that it provides problems and
iterating on that there's a question as
to
whether
which of those how we can sort of
combine the approaches local content and
then after the approach is to improve
that
and we have a lot of students who are
really invested in getting a certificate
and having something to show
for the work they've done and i'm
curious if you've developed a mechanism
for
giving people that kind of certified
sense of accomplishment or if there's
going to be antibiotics yeah i'm glad
you asked that question because that's
definitely something a lot of people
have asked us
am i going to get something like a
certificate which i can use
to get a job
and right now
since we are not a physical organization
we can
did not start
providing these certificates but what we
did was to partner with local
universities in bangladesh
for example we have a partnership with
the top engineering school in bangladesh
where
they are teaching a mobile application
development short course
and students who participate on the on
all the
lectures as well as submit the homeworks
do the project they'll get a course
completion certificate from that
university
it's not an official degree but it's
still a something that makes the
students happy
do you encourage students to engage with
each other offline so like in their
rural areas
do you encourage them to work together
to use each other
well right now um a lot of the students
do engage with each other on uh social
media for example on facebook
we haven't uh got to the phase where we
can uh encourage the students um to do
like offline real life collaborations
but maybe that's something we can think
about in future are people using that
technique in these kinds of situations
encouraging
so for one of our other x courses on
public health we
download the video and then brought it
to like rural areas for
people more in the field in the public
health sector and they would um go over
the lectures together and the content
together in the rural area um because
there is no internet
all right very slow how did they
identify the other course participants
or how do they know each other existed
um so we partnered with um
a global wing partner but this is um
uh paul farmer and arthur clement and um
partners in health i think that they
partnered with local i think
they partnered with local
organizations that like have public
health
just started something
with schools for example
we just talked to a principal of a
school in a really rural area right in
the heart of the sundarbans jungle he
wanted to get our courses on dvds so
what we're doing is to send
all the course lectures to in dvds to
them and they can show they can have a
special class after school in their
school for the students and then
encourage the students to
use that material but definitely this is
a very good idea maybe we can explore
that
about the certification because that's
the number one thing everybody does
before you know they want a piece of
paper that they can print and you know
them even we send it to them we're like
you know this is not signed by the
instructor
so my question just ties back to how
you're getting the courses in is is
there are you thinking sort of any
quality assurance mechanism that then
you can go and take to a degree
institution and you say you know this
course was one reviewed by these people
who work online and then is there
something like that
since we are very new right now i am
doing all the quality assurance in terms
of
like teaching style and lecture quality
and so on but in terms of contents we do
have some
from time to time i would ask an expert
in any particular area for example we
have a
math professor uh who taught one of our
courses we i often ask him to evaluate
other math courses uh is the course
going on well or not
so that's a way of doing quality control
and uh in
in other cases i think the students can
do the best quality control because if
they have two courses
on the same topic the best one will
probably be more popular with the
students
so it's kind of like a
discussion on that on that there's a
hypothesis ragib has posed a hypothesis
i'm curious what the rest of the room
what either from your experience or
whatever what you think about that
something you said earlier though about
the um
mix the the specific relevance for the
curriculum
or especially for things that actually
have things related to curriculum and so
like one of the things that we found is
that stuff that we were doing we were
doing an algorithms course okay so
the evaluation the way that you pass the
course and the actual exam set by the
universities is terrible
and it doesn't really show any kind of
evidence you've mastered algorithms now
you know we as a computer science
organization we really care about this
we care about do you actually master the
material well the students are like i
don't give a damn
because i i want to pass the course and
so you're giving me all this extra crap
that's that's not going to help you guys
and so it's a really difficult thing to
get
straight there
yeah so that that brings me the
that also reminds me of the question um
that's what students say they want and
what they actually want are sometimes
different we i did not mention a
server result i just recently got when i
asked do you want to study just to pass
the course and topics that are in the
course curriculum or do you want to
study for the sake of learning something
a huge majority of the students claim
that they want to study for the sake of
study but in reality if it doesn't help
them to pass then probably skip that
course
so do you give like suggestions like for
example say take these courses together
or like you know to go from one level to
the other other because like you know
people they might be interested in
something they say high school students
at least for
at least for programming languages we do
have a hierarchy of courses ranging from
uh the first few steps in programming
all the way to object-oriented
programming and others so there we
suggest to students that take these
courses in this sequence
but for other courses where kind of
leave the leave it up to the students if
they want something
they can just grab it
yeah
two questions um is do you do you know
if your students are tending to take
this uh instead of going to a
traditional university or college or
they're trying to sort of do something
complimentary
and so that's which number one um and
the question number two
is just about sort of opportunity for
them to demonstrate their knowledge
again especially with technology
programming languages like you're using
app developer sort of going somewhere
else to say like to
do what you're teaching them to do um
do you ever get requests for
more feedback on that kind of work just
like i want somebody to look at my app
or look at my code and like help me out
with it because that's why i'm running
the journal
yes students
would often talk or request the teacher
for help like that for example if that
creating a mobile app or they're doing
like a graphics design they would often
request the teacher to help them out
with a particular problem or so on
and uh what's the first question here
well it's up to the teacher because
everyone are volunteers the teachers are
volunteers they are not supposed to
answer to
or spend a lot of time on the students
but sometimes i've noticed that other
students if they post this on the
course's facebook page or
the
comment sections sometimes other
students would step in and help the
student that particular problem
and the other i think you mentioned
something about whether the students are
taking courses instead of going to
actual schools in some cases that is
precisely what's happening because some
people who are outside the traditional
education system because of poverty or
something else they often learn uh
something uh through our
courses an example was later i got it
from a student who had to drop out of um
high sc dropout of studying after high
school because couldn't afford to go to
colleges he said that his dream was to
become a computer engineer but he has
now working as a computer operator in a
village computer shop so he's very happy
to have these courses because in his
spare time he can just learn a new topic
going through our courses
so this is a broader question for
everyone in the room but so um i'm very
interested in it so what you've done is
you know obviously think about the local
context and the local language but
there's a lot of people out there
developing open educational resources
under creative commons licenses and
depending on where that content
originates it's in its own local you
know has a local cultural
artifacts within that content so
i was just wondering about any lessons
learned or
you know something i've been thinking
about a lot is how to best make those
materials so that they can be used in a
variety of contexts by a variety of
students
or people from the us from whatever
country so you know the ones i've
developed are you know they are in
english um they definitely have
cultural intonations from from the us we
were actually developing these videos
though to be used in singapore and the
english-speaking university so we did
try to think about about the sort of
cultural references as much as possible
and we still did get some feedback from
students that you know some things were
still very us
like so any lessons learned from anybody
here in the audience about you know
experiencing experience developing open
educational resources and how can we
make them to be best repurposed by
others for cost-effective um
for educational dissemination questions
you also say what things were very u.s
what kind of things you read into i
think you know so we always try to use
real world examples to highlight the
they were videos in the stem areas to
highlight the concepts for students you
know both for motivational reasons and
to and to give concrete examples of the
content in use and so so because of i
think some of those those concrete
examples even though they were science
and engineering examples
for
for some students they felt like well
we're not familiar with that because of
where we live those those examples don't
necessarily resonate with us as much so
um dogs pulling a sled in the snow for
example
don't see the snow you know
i'll actually expand the problem a
little bit just to say that uh even
within the u.s and the statistics course
that we have in oli we've got a lot of
requests for examples that are specific
to the specific disciplines so we tried
to create we we took this into
account when we created the course and
try wherever possible make the examples
and activities very general
but even so we've got a lot of requests
for nursing statistics business
statistics and i actually think that
speaks to one of the
importances of the technology is we do
have the ability now to create uh so i
guess i don't know how far we get down
the general path versus how how much we
create multiple examples and multiple
pathways through the content that are
familiar to people in different uh in
different areas to address that problem
so
we're actually out of time so but thank
you all for uh coming to this uh session
and i hope the conversation continues
over lunch
thank you for being
mario one here